son lágrimas de alivio para este padre
que se reencuentra con sus hijas este
domingo numerosos visitantes se
encontraban en este centro comercial de
la periferia de copenhague algunos
habían venido para el concierto del
británico harry styles mientras que
otros hacían compras se encontraron en
una escena de oro
vieron que un tipo que salía de la
escalera mecánica empezó a disparar un
arma automática así que empezaron a
correr lo más rápido que pude casi dejar
el tirador llegó en la tarde con un arma
de grandes dimensiones
diciendo según los testigos que era
falsa pero disparó a la gente causando
la muerte de varias personas e hiriendo
a otras en un ambiente de pánico más de
100 personas escaparon corriendo
mientras que otros se escondieron dentro
del sitio
la policía llegó la gente seguía
corriendo no sé si ellos estaban
corriendo atrás de él era pánico no
estaba muy claro
la policía abrió una investigación sobre
lo sucedido
en el sur
los distingue son
en relación con la detención de nuestro
sospechoso que estamos convencidos de
que es el autor estaba en posesión de un
rifle y tenía munición para el rifle el
arresto fue poco dramático en relación
con su detención médica
es el ataque más mortífero que dinamarca
ha conocido el último tiroteo masivo
tuvo lugar en la capital en 2015 y dejó
2 muertos